let me talk to you guys about this we we
briefly mentioned it a couple days ago
the dead internet theory do you guys
know about the listing theory yeah from
the other day i remember this the dead
internet theory is that
in 2016 and 17
that's when
major corporations government figures
took over most social um elements of the
internet and replaced humans with bots
or that the bots dramatically outweigh
the production of content than humans do
so the internet is actually a zombie
you think you're interacting with other
people just like you but you're really
just interacting with bots
and it's it's a decent theory i mean the
idea is simple
donald trump was memed into the
presidency
regular people went online and said
here's what we want trump wins and they
went uh-oh that's bad
then you get a bunch of companies that
start running stock puppet accounts and
bot accounts trying to make money or
manipulate and not it's not a conspiracy
even though they call it a conspiracy
theory it's like the natural tendency of
what corporations would do to try and
gain influence and sell products but i
got one more for you this one's for you
guys uh sheamus and seth
i think this is um
bot person theory
the actual the actual conspiracy theory
in my opinion is that 2016 2017 is the
point at which the internet
crossed the threshold of being the most
dominant media
network
for human beings
newspapers television telephone were now
underneath the internet
and with all people being online we're
now realizing that most people are as
dumb as a box of rocks effectively
non-player characters so
to uh to to somebody who's used to
having a real conversation to being um
you know uh politically discerning or
introspective they're seeing a whole
bunch of people post the same thing
repeat themselves
regurgitate
and this this other theory started the
person basically said i have seen the
same post over and over again i've seen
the same comments repeated at nauseum
and i'm just like
you want to believe the robots but it
could just be that most people are just
sheep and are just vomiting up the same
thing they heard and the reality is it's
people
that's the creepy thing i i think it's a
better explanation it's if if i'm there
and i'm real and you're there and you're
real and you're there and you're we're
all there we're real
there's a lot of real people there it's
not all bots there's obviously a lot of
people involved in this thing it's not
all dead
and people do just parrot these lines
over and over and it's mindless you know
they just they just say whatever they're
supposed to say
and or what they've heard they
regurgitate what they've heard
i see it all the time and it seems like
bot behavior but it's really just people
we are we have become bots we're
basically just machines just
regurgitating stuff
yeah and uh you got to be you got to be
careful not to fall into that trap
yourself when you're engaging with them
well then you just start saying what
you're supposed to say in response to
that and you're engaging in your own you
know like
that's why i post nonsense on twitter
that's why i said you know figuratively
throw a pie like do something weird i
posted an ai trump as a chicken yeah i
was you know i've always i thought this
my whole life
i was just like how come no one ever
does anything unpredictable like it's
not really true that's never but 80 of
the time it's completely predictable 20
of the time you're gonna be surprised by
what someone does and i was just like
for the most part everybody's walking
around doing exactly what you'd expect
them to do not a single person decides
to do anything weird that's why some
people do sorry they're all just
thinking really weird things yeah that's
when i started making internet videos
like what would jesus christ do with
this modern technology he'd make
internet videos and try and spread the
got so i was like i'll do it
and so i did it and that was weird and
it's not me that's not weird i'm
completely routine and boring of course
everyone's doing it right um it's it's
the natural order what i'm saying is
like how come no one's buying
porta-potties and labeling them shelly
more capital
you know you know what i mean like
you've got all these powerful wealthy
people who are complaining but doing
nothing or doing very little
i think the power of making an internet
video is is misunderstood it's it's not
quite the power you have the resonation
of your vibration through voice and
light is so powerful dude if i'm if i
made 50 million bucks a year or
something like that i would just go to
these companies and be like how many how
much will it cost to buy like 10 times
square billboards and just put up the
same thing just doing something weird
like ragging on shelly more capital well
so i i will answer with the jordan
peterson quote right
it's like it's not many people are
creative it's not obvious why you would
want to be because like creative people
are miserable when they're not doing
creative things and he sort of had this
very insightful interesting explanation
there but
yeah it's basically that i mean most
people are not creative in the way that
we usually define the term
and so
they're not interested in doing those
kinds of things i think when somebody is
more creative and they do have means
they're often afraid to do anything
interesting with it man that's lame just
because uh sure but i think it's the way
things are because they're afraid of
being told john's
is a very unique example right and we we
sort of we talked about this with jeremy
boring right we're just sort of
comparing elon to bezos and he described
bezos like the most good the most boring
interesting person or most interesting
boring person it's like he builds a
rocket but it's not cool right
exactly exactly uh so i think you see a
lot of that um is it do you think that
people with means that are creative
they're afraid of being told that they
suck well no so i think that's part of
it i think that everyone has an excuse
not to do the interesting thing they
want to do
so when you don't have a lot of money
it's i could never do this because i
couldn't afford to then when you do have
money well i could never do this because
i could never afford to damage my
reputation or risk my wealth i guess
people are scared of their reputations
or something yeah that's the biggest
brand yeah
people yeah yeah people always have been
i think we put more emphasis on it today
and i think we've been trained to we
become very narcissistic but it's it's
huge isn't there a point where you just
have so much money they say it's fu
money but it's not it's not i
i mean let's be real can we name
i guess elon musk is buying twitter
which is cool it's not particularly
outrageous
it did anger many people on the left but
it's actually a relatively
i i you it's it's it's a big it's a big
bold move but it's not throwing a pie
you know what i mean you don't think so
no no no throwing a pie would be like
buying a super bowl commercial or buying
a billboard of ian and hollywood just
saying i remember you and just like
culture jamming well i just from my
perspective i never expected you know i
was i was trying to think to myself what
would be a possible solution to this
issue of viewpoint discrimination
happening on these platforms you know
like
there's either going to be some kind of
a law that's passed possibly you know
congress could get involved and draft
legislation or the courts could do
something i never in a million years
thought oh well maybe the richest man in
the world is going to come along
describe himself as a free speech
absolutist and buy the platform and fix
the problem you know it was it was a it
was a a curveball it was unexpected so
if you go back to the point that you're
making about no one ever does anything
unexpected like who expects that
someone's going to come in and offer
more than the company's worth just to
make a point about how this needs to be
for speech i would say it's uh it's on
the line you know a rich guy buying
something expensive is like okay it is
it is surprising that someone made a
move like that but it's not like if elon
came out and said he was going to put
100 million dollars into making a rival
news organization that would be like
whoa and if and but i will say elon
definitely fits the bill definitely um
because he tweets things that like aoc
like stopped making me blush like yeah
absolutely amazing yeah but so he's
definitely doing it he trolls people
very effectively very nice i think it's
also a definitional problem right
because if you're asking why aren't
people usually doing things that are
unpredictable if they were it would be
predictable i mean by definition for
something to be unpredictable it has to
happen infrequently but you like
i'm just saying
there are a lot of very wealthy people
that are and many of them are are
somewhat uh directly or tendentially
involved in like culture war issues
and like how come nobody just does bold
weird things save elon right because you
know he tweet tweeting him tweeting at
aoc was hilarious buying twitter is
massive it's like
i'm just i i've talked about this many
times there's very few people who just
do the weird thing what donald trump did
with the uh the apprentice that was so
weird
and then he did the president thing yeah
but then he ran for president and he
always kind of was weird that one was
weird
we can acknowledge we can acknowledge
like we've said this a number of times
if you told someone 10 years ago that
trump was going to be president and the
deep state was going to try to see him
and everything that's happened we would
go i don't believe that just some weird
things seriously just pause for a second
imagine it's 2012 and you're like
sitting with your buddy and like you're
in the living room and you're and you're
he's like you're like i've come back
from the future 10 years and he's like
wow what happened you're like okay well
uh donald trump ran for president
against hillary clinton and won and then
a bunch of special interests accused him
of secretly working with russia and even
msnbc had a guest on entertaining that
he may have been a soviet agent going
back to the 80s uh he ultimately won
then joe biden gets elected donald trump
supporters think the election was stolen
so a large several hundred stormed the
capitol building during the electoral uh
the actual vote counting process texas
filed a lawsuit against pennsylvania and
half the country and other half the
country are now involved in whether or
not the election was legitimate they're
going to be like
what
that's neat
so was obama's birth certificate real or
fake yeah
did we get to
uh what i mean it's like cause obviously
elon musk is doing funny things but like
he's not doing funny things like buying
a hundred port-a-potties and putting the
name of a senator on it and distributing
them around fairgrounds i think you
should just do it you're fixated on that
you really want to change what you want
to see in the world
it's a really good example no no it's
800 per porta potty oh yeah so you know
it so we
spend eighty thousand dollars on a
hundred portal bodies and then just be
like they're free
you know like oh what's that you're
doing called construction companies and
be like we'll just give it to you just
use it and they're called jelly boxes
i think another thing that happens and
this is really insidious and it's not
accounted for often but
there's an entire set of behaviors that
we are told are weird and quirky and
interesting but which are really boring
and predictable
so a lot of folks feel like they're
doing something unique or new when
they're just sort of going along with
the program so
there are a lot of examples of this we
see this with the activism a lot of
these companies engage in where they'll
they'll make their corporate logo a gay
pride flag or something it's okay well
that's the most predictable thing you
can do but you think it's edgy and brave
and interesting
or at least for a time they did at this
point they're probably willing to
acknowledge that this is just the thing
you're
and don't do and don't forget july is
maga month so everyone's got to change
their logos to american flags and i'm
i'm doing it i'm gonna i'm gonna get
graphics made you know my twitter
profile will be my face with the
american flag behind it i like that but
i mean how often i'm sure we've all
encountered this where somebody gives
you the most banal predictable
advertiser friendly perspective as if
it's something new and original
all the time i mean it's constant it's
like whenever someone's like you know
what like i don't like christianity or
like well i
and it's like okay i it's like i
understand that but can you acknowledge
that that's a very safe position but
people don't do that anymore like their
view has to be unique and interesting
even when it's plainly banal
i wonder if it's just
you know if in from
in my perspective most people they play
music because they looked up to someone
and want to emulate somebody else most
people just want to emulate someone else
so they want to fit in they want to stay
in line i wonder how many people
genuinely don't care about fitting in
and i wonder if that's technically like
a mental illness no i mean it because
humans are social beings you want to fit
in to survive so it takes a very rare
individual to be like literally don't
care if i fit in or not like what would
what would i do if you know we were like
nomadic tribesmen you know thousands of
years ago and i was being arrogant like
i don't want to do what you say screw
you the bet get out and i'd be like well
i'm going to go die i guess in the
middle of the woods
so it's like i talk about making these
shelly boxes
but would people really be like you're
would they be like that's great or
they'd be like you're really disrupting
what we're trying to do here i made
outhouse put poster on it they'd be like
get leave now yeah
rug they're like this is
leading our tribe leave now
or or is the reality that the the
outliers and the weirdos end up being
the leaders
sometimes sometimes they're snuffed out
you never hear about them i think what
ends up happening is a sociopath uh
like the the narcissists and the
egotists end up becoming the leaders
people who are like i should be in
charge and then once they're in charge
like i can lie cheat and steal whatever
it was i'm better than you i think ben
franklin was a nut job but he was so
organized that he was able to create uh
a periodical you know the poor richard's
almanac and distribute propaganda for 30
years to brainwash people into thinking
that freedom was the way and that they
should revolt against the king so he
worked out
do what ben franklin did
fly a kite in a storm with a key on it
yeah
absorb electricity it's time to do that
too get weird
i'm starting to buy into
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you